[Keep 'Em Out]
[Produced by Stark-Films in cooperation with
the U. S. Public Health Service]
Images of bombs falling and buildings exploding,
fire, and debris flying.
[Narrator:] The war is on. The enemy is attacking
on American soil. Our armed forces will take
care of the human invaders, but there is another
enemy, a vile destroyer of property, homes,
and lives who we must fight in every American
community. And it's everybody's fight.
Let us look more closely into the rubble left
by this explosion.
There. There he is. Our enemy, the rat. He's
about as loathsome a creature as we know,
the bottom word in anybody's language. Look
at that wicked countenance. Ooh. The mere
sight of it gives you gooseflesh.
This natural abhorrence of rats is old as
man himself and for these reasons:
They do tremendous damage to our buildings,
gnawing
holes, weakening structures, ruining plumbing,
and starting fires.
They ruin large quantities of food and other
supplies, destroying ten times as much as
they eat, and polluting great quantities more
that might have been eaten by human beings.
[Sign reading Quarantined By order Health
Dept.]
And most important, they carry diseases, including
the dread plague and typhus fever.
Sometimes the diseased germs are carried on
the rat's feet.
But more often, the infection is spread by
secondary parasites like lice and fleas.
The infected flea leaves a sick or dead rat,
attaches
himself to a live, healthy one, and is thus
taken into the rat's nest where fleas live
and breed abundantly.
Infected fleas are then carried from the nest
into your home or the place you work or shop
or visit, where they are knocked off by the
rat's scratching.
They hop around on the floor until time for
the next meal. You provide this next meal,
and you become infected through the break
in your skin where the bite occurs.
It is the close association of rats and man
living together which constitutes a health
menace. Prevent this association, and you
break the chain of infection.
The rat is by far our most costly mammalian
pest and the most dangerous animal enemy of
man.
[Map of U.S. with figure of 150,000,000 next
to image of rat displayed atop it.]
In the United States, there are more rats
than human inhabitants. It costs approximately
two dollars a year to feed one rat, and the
estimated annual board bill in this country
alone is well over 300 million dollars, a
rather high figure for an unwelcome guest,
especially in times like these.
You might well ask why do we pay for it? Public
health officials know how to get rid of rats
and the story can be told in three short lines.
Block their entrance into buildings, eliminate
enclosed spaces where they nest, catch and kill.
It is always better to know the enemy before
we begin to fight. By studying his habits
and needs, we discover the weak points of
his defense, and then we can strike where
it will do most good.
For example, rats hug the wall when climbing
stairs. So we catch them with traps placed
near the wall.
Rafters like these are no barrier
to a rat's progress, but on them, he leaves
his mark.
We recognize the signs and place traps in
the way. We know that rats eat meat, grain,
vegetables, garbage, almost anything, and
they will do seemingly impossible things in
order to get at food.
Take this fellow, for instance, gnawing through
a lead pipe. And here is as good an exhibition
of wire walking as you've ever seen at the
circus.
This rat knows that the wire leads to food.
After he gets to the building, he must find
an opening into the house. The instinct to
nest and reproduce is as strong as the instinct
to eat. So rats naturally seek a home.
Usually, they don't have to go to much trouble
to find homes because we provide these for
them, made to order, steam-heated. Everything
but the welcome mat.
These are typical examples of conditions and
factors responsible for the presence of rats
in our buildings.
And don't think they're necessarily slum-dwellers.
They will live in any building that provides
harborage, even homes like this.
We know that rats are very prolific, producing
litters of five to ten every couple of months.
According to estimates of the United States
Fish and Wildlife Service, they are the most
prolific of all mammals, and a single pair
of rats left to reproduce unhampered would
become 1,500 in a year.
And 360 million in the short space of three
years.
Of course, they're not allowed to multiply
unhampered. So the situation is not quite
so bad. It's plenty bad enough, however, and
high time we took the offensive and counterattacked.
Here are a few of the things you can do. Get
rid of old rubbish. Eliminate enclosed spaces
in which rats might nest - under platforms,
under stairs, under houses.
Close openings around pipes and wires. Or
better still, make such openings to fit exactly
the pipes they admit, and put metal collars
around them to prevent breaks or gnawing.
Rats will not burrow in the ground deeper
than 20 inches. So make the foundations of
your buildings rat-proof two feet below and
one foot above ground.
Concrete or a metal sheet sunk along the building
wall will serve this purpose.
Avoid double walls where possible, but if
you use them, be sure they are kept intact
so rats cannot run between them. Blocks and
jams help.
Cover basement windows and other openings
with wire mesh or perforated sheet steel.
Any opening larger than half an inch will
admit rats. If you can get your forefinger
into it, a rat can squeeze through.
Where wire mesh or glass is used, it must
be protected and kept intact. Once broken,
your protection is gone. Wherever possible,
use rat-proof materials: metal, concrete,
plaster, stone, bricks, or tile.
This door is flashed with metal, and the door
pull keeps it closed when not in use.
Concrete is the most nearly perfect material
for rat-proofing. Repair breaks in walls as
soon as they are discovered in order to keep
'em out.
Buildings where food is kept must be unusually
well-protected, like this one with concrete
floor, brick walls, and tight-fitting metal
door.
Finally, there should be periodic inspections
to see that buildings are properly maintained.
Fight rats with knowledge. Ask your health
department for help. Rat control is up to you.
While individual effort can do a lot, the
concerted effort of the whole community is
needed to solve the problem completely.
Eternal vigilance and a well-planned continuing
program should be our answer to this challenge.
So long, rat. The outlook for you is not very
good.
[ Music and image of plump rat.]
Keep them out!
[The End, Stark Films]